- rats Galatz a cold Blackstar Ben  Holly's worth and his wife Neela  each he has exclusive photos of the  couple and a new baby boy named  Hemingway Nash Hollingsworth the proud  parents welcomed their bundle of joy on  Sunday  weighing in at 7 pounds and seven ounces  from the looks of these intimate images  they couldn't be more happy then also  shared on Instagram this pic of his son  captioning it this little man  now owns my heart the actor adds mommy  and baby are healthy happy and currently  cuddling after an easy labor in which  mommy could not stop smiling even when  she was pushing I was given the  opportunity to catch him at birth and  now that I have him a never letting go  then and his wife were married in  November 2012 following a two-month  engagement Hemingway's their first child  together